hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was played yesterday
uh on daniel neroditsky's stream uh he's
playing against uh world church
championship candidates uh participant
maxima shalom who is currently leading
uh the candidates tournament alongside
yanni pomnishi
and the game comes as a suggestion from
a subscriber
uh marcel josu so thank you for that
marcel it's it's a beautiful game and
it's
just what we need for the for the
upcoming holidays
uh so without further ado let's check it
out it's a three
plus zero game i believe so uh you know
a nice short blitz game
uh let's see what happens here now
nardinski with the white pieces opens
with e4 sorry about that uh and here uh
maxime
uh maxime goes for c6 he goes for the
karo khan defense
and it's very interesting uh because uh
well with all the
fuss about the queen's gambit uh we'll
see if uh the
the opening truly is all pawns and no
hope so c6 the karo khan is on the board
we have knight to c3 and now
d5 striking in the center we have knight
to f3 uh by daniel uh
and now uh d captures on e4 we have
knight captures and now just knight to
f6
so the the two knights attack we have
queen to e2 now threatening a very
sneaky checkmate
uh uh i played this i don't know how
many times it's uh
when you pl when you for example create
a new account and first you you're gonna
have to play against uh
a lot of uh well lower rated opponents
and then anything can happen
and then you your opponent might play
something like knight to d7
and you can just finish the game with a
nice knight to d6 uh discovered
uh smothered mate or just a small as
muttered mate
but of course maxim is not about to fall
for that he trades knights captures
captures and now plays
knights to d7 preparing to bring the
other knight over to f6
and this is all uh very very standard
theory we have bishop to c4 and now
knight to f6 attacking the queen and now
another
attempt at a trick knight to e5 but this
is not uh it's not that naruto is just
trying some tricks that this is actually
confirmed uh standard theory of this
line and this is by far the
the most played move in this position so
knight e5
idea being that if the queen is captured
bishop captures on f7 is checkmate so of
course
black cannot accept the queen sacrifice
we have e6
and now queen back to e2 now black of
course is
uh very happy to accept the queen so
queen e2
and bishop to b5 making room for the
bishop and v7 charging the bishop
bishop to b3 and here uh this position
has been reached i think in the database
in top tier games
about 11 times and queen to c7 and
quinta b6 are the moves that have been
played here
and interestingly there's only uh one
position where
white actually won this game and uh it
was uh in the game
paco versus baskaran adiban uh but other
than that it was
either a draw or black one this game or
no it's the other way around uh let me
just check that
real quickly uh serves me right for
trying to memorize everything
uh just give me a second all right there
we go
all right no no no
i i i said it correctly like all the
games were won by black only one game uh
one by white here however
here king bishop to b7 was played and
this is a terrible move
by maxine probably mixed up the move
order or maybe he's not
familiar with the exact same position
but it allows for a very
uh very wild attack from white's side
so feel free to pause the video and uh
well find the winning move for
naradiski here while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
move that
uh begins the king hunt and for those
who just want to enjoy the show
it's knight captures on f7 and now you
grab the pawn the queen and rook are
under attack
black really doesn't have a better move
than to accept the knight but
then the queen and bishop are attacking
the e6 pawn because when the bishop was
moved from c8 to b7
it no longer uh has control of the e6
pawn and this is just a
uh start of uh of a terrible day for
maxime so came to have seven
queen captures on e6 with czech king to
g6
and now queen to f7 with check
continuing the king hunt king to f5
and now comes g4 with check
other than this g4 check id also
possible is bishop to e6 check
uh but uh you know it it all depends on
what you prefer it's a three-minute game
you can't spend all that much time uh
trying to look for the quickest way but
uh this is definitely quickest because
after king e5
d4 check and you just open up all of the
lines if queen captures
you can just castle here rook is coming
to e1 bishop can come to e3 the other
rook to d1
and the king is well will soon uh
die a terrible and painful death so here
after king to f5
with g4 and nardiski prefers to continue
the
wild king hunt king captures of course
the knight cannot uh
capture and uh not capturing you know
you kind of don't want to capture
because then you allow rook to g1 check
you open up the g file for the rook but
if you go here then
uh you open up the the light square
bishop and it's not not much better so
king captures on g4 or rook to g1 with
check and now
king to h3 and interestingly
uh here black is completely lost it's
actually a forced
checkmate in nine but if only only the
first two moves are what matters uh
because then
after that uh black will just have to
give up pieces for no reason to just
survive a few more moves
so feel free to pause the video once
again and try to spot this
sneaky sequence while i give you a
couple of seconds once again
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
ending uh black uh very swiftly and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
queen e6 with check and now you don't
really have a good move here uh if you
go king capture here then king to f1
defends the rook and uh well
it's just game over uh rook to g2 is
coming and of course if king the h4
then queen to f5 so that was the
maneuver you had to spot and now again
it's all over
uh not much you can do here it's just uh
well a very quick checkmate and there's
nothing you can do even if h6
preventing g5 you can still just check
uh check the
king for example h6 queen f4 checking
goes back then bishop to f7 check is an
idea
and it just all falls apart we can even
show it as it's quite nice queen of four
check
king can go to h5 now bishop to f7 check
and now the rook and bishop attack this
bishop to g6 will be checkmate
so there are so many uh beautiful
checkmates uh
in this game that haven't happened but
we are going to show them so here rook
the g3
check instead and this is of course much
more aesthetically pleasing as you want
to bring the black king uh
deep into your own position as much as
possible so king captures an h2
and now comes bishop to e6 here
nordisk's plan is bishop to e6 and king
to f1 and then of course
rook to g2 will just be checkmate king
to f1 is
much more precise than starting with
bishop to e6 because
uh you'll see what happens in the game
bishop to e6
and now of course maxine goes queen to
d6 which would not be
a viable plan if king to f1 was played
first because now
uh he will give up the queen for the
rook of course white is still completely
winning it it would just be
much faster so king f1 queen captures on
g3
and now f captures on g3 and now rook to
e8 so here
naruditsuki is completely winning uh but
maxime was able to survive and maybe he
can
do some damage he still has two rooks a
bishop a knight anything can still
happen
so here queen captures on b7 only good
move for white
rook captures and now queen captures on
a7 preparing to bring the queen into the
attack now
uh with knight to e4 by black and
queen to g1 with check king h3 and now
queen to h1 with
check luckily the knight is protected so
king captures in g3 and now
d3 attacking the knight and finally open
up this uh dark square bishop
rook to f6 with check king to e2 and
now rook to f2 check doesn't really do
anything you can just play king e1
and now not much for black to do here
so after king e2 we have knight to f2
with an attack on against white's queen
and now queen g1 check king h3 and now
bishop to e3 now the knight is under
attack twice you have to do something
uh although not much for you to do there
bishop the b4 was played
uh now trying to offer the knight here
for example if you capture the knight
here
then maybe some damage can be done with
a rook to e8 check the bishop covers
this diagonal but it's very unlikely
so instead after bishop to b4 queen
captures and g7 was played
and uh it was uh well not in this
position that
uh maxime resigned he played one more
move he played rook h2f8 but
then uh the game is almost over feel
free to pause the video
for the last time and win this game for
white in the quickest way possible
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding
rook to g1 as this is the quickest way
to victory
rook to g1 and it was in this position
that maksim vashila grav
the leader of the candidates tournament
2020 resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh there are too many checkmating
options for white for example a queen
captures an h7 rook here
queen captures with checkmate if you
somehow prevented that
checkmate let's say h5 then even queen
to g3 is checkmate so there are
two too many checkmates happening all at
once for for black to handle and of
course he was in this position that
maxim resigned in the game
so a beautiful game and really thanks uh
thanks again
uh marcel jose for recommending it i i
seriously doubt i would have
found out about it if you haven't
suggested it and we would uh
you know be be bereft of such uh such a
brilliancy
especially against such a strong player
like uh like maxine
so big congratulations to narudinsky on
his fine
victory against such a strong player and
yeah that's it hope you guys
enjoyed it uh and yeah also something i
wanted to show you guys
here is the accuracy at which the game
was played uh also an option you can do
on chess.com
uh for example narudic played this game
with a 98.3
accuracy that that's what it takes to
take down maxime like this
and uh if it if if this game was any
more correct
it would only mean that you know
checkmate would maybe happen faster
but other than that the the the game was
always uh
better for white at no point in the game
black even had a chance
unless white made a terrible mistake so
yeah
once again i do hope you guys enjoyed it
merry christmas to everyone if i don't
make a video tomorrow i hope i will but
you know you never know
what tomorrow holds uh i would like to
thank antonio jesus carrasco uh paul
rebecca
bjorn bartel jeffrey clement and james
eugene cashman for a contribution to my
channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon continuing with the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
any wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the world
uh
uh which is a lot actually as we have
another big tournament featuring magnus
and
and the the the fellowship starting from
26th
of december i i think until third of
january
uh but yeah uh thank y'all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day